this ain't never coming off
i don't care what miranda does and we
owe
till that do his part
you might want to grab a box of tissues
because the latest episode of hbo max's
sex in the city revival series and just
like that is heartbreak city population
steve we came back to
to throw these characters into new
situations and let them
you know follow their hearts the episode
picks up after this gut-wrenching moment
from last week
is this really happening are you asking
me for a divorce
this is really happening really
why so she could pursue a relationship
with che i think it was very bold we're
not going to be treading water we're
actually going to be sailing into
completely unchartered waters
you look especially pretty tonight oh
thank you
and you look especially
whatever acceptable non-polarizing
gender positive compliment you feel
comfortable with
you are a lot of fun there's definitely
a lot to take in between these two and
the possibilities are endless i think
that these two
characters might inspire each other
to um i don't know show up in a way that
could develop something really really
exciting and electric
and things with che well
let's just say it's not all romantic
bliss
surprise
oh my god did we have a plan
did i space no
no no no
i was studying at the library and was
craving me some jay so i hopped on the
train hi
okay
this is awkward
oh it's awkward all right i'm in the
middle of writing and i kind of wish you
would have texted or called not a
problem i'm gonna go this isn't gonna
work
if you lock us into those [ __ ]
limiting relationship tropes
you know guys do this and girlfriends do
that this isn't cosplay i'm not a guy
you're not my girlfriend and we're not
dating we're not
what are we doing
what i really love about che diaz is
they really are not afraid to speak
their truth i also think it's really
wonderful that we have the first
non-binary series regular character in
the universe of sex in the city
as for steve well he shows up with their
son brady to help miranda paint a
women's shelter
well that's very impressive well yeah so
is steve and when he gets paired up to
paint with carrie he has a lot of
questions about che
did you know that miranda wanted to be
with women
no she she never said that
all i know is what she said to me
that it's not about being with women
it's about
being with che
but even after hearing all that steve
says for him it's till death do us part
this ain't never coming off don't you
maybe
want to find someone
at some point
never coming off
fans will just have to wait to see what
happens between steve miranda and che
but one thing's for sure we want a
season two and when e.t recently chatted
with cynthia nixon she played coy about
the possibility i am not a writer and so
that is one of the great privileges of
not being a writer is it's not my job to
figure it out you know thank god but in
terms of the the amazing writers that we
have dreaming things up
they know much better than i
you